movie rips off the opening shot his
space and a sudden large spaceship
flying past the camera thing from well
science fiction in general but just
because it's easier to pick one Star
Wars
come on guys we made dinosaurs look
realistic back in 1993 with Jurassic
Park how if we devolved so much after 21
years the Arctic you might as well just
say someplace cold or earth where the
did these come from
remember the establishing shot no I see
dinosaurs to be found remember the shot
just before this yeah those are the same
bulldozers and everything with nothing
but rocks in case you thought Texas
could be anywhere else and just like the
Arctic it's so unda scripta vas to be
not worth pointing out in the first
place you might as well just say America
guitar strumming will convert the
wealthy one-time marky-mark into a
simple man character we can all relate
to I think it's pretty obvious that the
Billboard would actually read Chicago
strong city name strong is clearly the
rallying cry format for tragedies based
in American cities right also remember
Chicago probably a good idea but today
I'm gonna remember Peter Cetera also who
puts billboards in cornfields on
deserted dirt and country s roads the
movies nowadays that's the trouble
sequels and remakes bunch of crap phew
you don't get to make this joke after
building an entire career out of this
theater owner is bemoaning that's like
having your cake eating it and then
saying cake I'm above it you know folks
used to come from miles around to see
the dancing girls with the big shot just
swear to God I am one diaper change away
from poisoning his oatmeal in 1492
Christopher Columbus sailed the ocean
blue you see I can make no sense
- so prime basically got shot to hell
after the last movie and then I guess
drove his ass all the way from Mexico
City to this theater in Texas and then
just pooped out without anyone noticing
few more weeks girls no more classes
ever yep that's exactly how teenage
girls talk to each other either her
friends read the script and nube wanted
this long driveway shot or else they're
assholes for dropping her off so far
from her actual house the bottle of
Chicago is that what the news is calling
the alien invasion that happened in the
middle of Chicago because that sounds
just like a forgotten battle of the
Civil War to me previously on
Transformers a act of Congress put an
end to all joint operations between the
military and the Autobots wasn't this
already done before the invasion the
Autobots were all being sent off in a
rocket remember so Congress after
everything that happened decided to pass
the exact same legislation they did just
before the invasion also these movies
need to stop giving us stupid reasons
why the Autobots aren't wanted or needed
plus it's gonna add another 30 damn
minutes to this movie to bring them back
another five minutes to this video
expressing our disbelief in the age of
the Transformers is over can we just get
to the robot fighting and forget about
all this also by my stars and garters is
that Kelsey Grammer how Skype would
actually work is you'd call the person
first then fail three times then finally
get them it definitely doesn't happen
with a few clicks of the keyboard also
few movie and Skype for showing us a
practically 4k HD viewing experience
that is 100% not possible
dead hot mom cliche family with money
problems has amazing internet connection
and daughter has all the Bhoots what did
you say
a hot teenager you can find some kind of
pedophilia joke in nearly every Michael
Bay movie we call him on excessive
explosions or casual racism but joking
about a grown man fucking a teenager
when you look the other way I own this
house for sale does the bank actually
try and sell your house by sending out a
realtor before they foreclose because no
they don't
holy Sh that is the girl from The Last
Airbender and her acting hasn't improved
one bit actually it's gotten worse I
promise you one day I'm gonna build
something that matters character
believes stupidly impossible thing that
will no doubt turn out to be true just
like the key dustbowl Shia believed in
so much how do we know they're evil
they're in black SUVs and tailgating got
a he'd soon a heat sig Kappa near
Energon detectors fire they're firing
this very likely inaccurate weapon at
the ship while they have troops on the
boat and a helicopter in the air we're
all in danger I lost a sister in Chicago
people know that the Decepticons
destroyed Chicago well before the
Autobots showed up right he's mine now
why do these powerful robots need the
military to help them do a job they
could easily do on their own do you know
I was for my graduation do you mean from
medical school because the backwards
baseball cap does not make you 18 all
the sudden shooting star wait the fuck
why is this spider-man 3 when it hooked
this back to a working battery yeah
because this alien technology totally
works with regular ass car batteries the
following line of dialogue is delivered
without sarcasm I'm an inventor this
could be a game-changer for me baby wait
he said help me with the pulley arm then
the girl walked into the house then he
was holding a missile that lifts up from
his grasp on its own and suddenly
Optimus is alive the three dragged his
mortal wound then your men allowed him
to escape again why do these assholes
need the CIA's help aside from
information why do they need the
military team to help them take down
Autobots you all think you're the center
of the universe you are no idea
and I guess the visit is over so that's
why they met out in the Arctic to talk
about a failed mission surely there was
a better reason to drag kelsey grammer
all the way out here than that I'm
trying to regs he's got hidden the hint
in the ten-foot cannon yeah about that
how'd you survive that anyway this
footage of Team Dead cemetery or
whatever the fuck is clearly at dawn but
seconds later we see HUD drive up to
Marky Mark's farm at what is clearly
midday my face is my Warren the director
said let's have your character eat an
apple and then throw it before you're
done it'll make you look like even more
of an asshole unnecessary slow motion
now got ten seconds twenty seconds later
CIA dude says seven surface and nineteen
seconds after that you've got two
seconds
also this cemetery wind team has
technology that reads heat signatures
how the hell did they miss this huge
heat signature in the barn super badass
alien missile technology hits the house
instead of the prime target come on bro
maybe the boyfriend ex machina I'd like
to remind everyone that this bull weapon
earlier hit its target no problem now
that they're firing at optimus nothing
works even at point-blank range
why was the one Decepticon they were
working with so far behind the humans in
this one instance what and thank God
because this is a jaysene discount the
lost world Jurassic Park did a magic
freeway show up in the middle of all
this farmland
sure let's just smash through the bingo
place no one could possibly get hurt
doing that Optimus and lockdown decide
to have a fight in the same random place
where our human heroes just happen to be
why does Optimus Prime always commit
completely heart and soul to the first
human that helps him a little bit for
all he knows Kate is a total asshole and
honestly he kind of is from what the
movies showing us so far pick out your
guns and shoot them hey smoke monster
guy why did you wait until now to give
this order come on you knew about this
little ramp on the fifth floor and you
knew there was another ramp at the
bottom and you've done this stunt before
well I'm not buying it but even if I did
it's no wonder this chick can't get a
scholarship
she's probably dumb for trusting anyone
to do this impossible stunt on a regular
basis movie sits and Ponder's what a
tragedy Lucas's death is so that you
won't ponder why the bomb totally missed
everyone else movie masturbates
Lamborghini shortly after supposedly
awful death scene
stay here till I'm sure we weren't
followed we
all targets now I had to transform into
a robot to say that just to transform
back and drive away
you've got your ass kicked by a garage
inventor from Texas oh and there was a
little matter of I don't know Optimus
Prime doing most of the damage but sure
let's make Kate Yeager the ass kicker so
why is he sound like a leprechaun that's
racist
oh no no no Lucky Charms are in Texas
that's racist
one driver one navigator huh just like
death race 2000 this movie thinks
drivers in the modern or future error
need physical human being navigators in
the car in order to race I just got
picked up by Red Bull and we all just
got dumped on by Red Bull I just call
the cops on you because this is illegal
she's a minor well protected by the
Romeo and Juliet laws are you kidding
this whole movie is being derailed by
statutory laws right now I could have
just made this girl 18 and Kade could
have been just as angry as he is now but
no we have to talk about goddamn
statutory rape laws right now statute
two-seven-zero foot that's three
actually the statute clearly says 20
2.01 one on the card you carry with you
so anyone who carries around a card like
this is some kind of rapist right this
is my license to bang underage chicks
right here hey you you're too old to be
fucking that teenager oh wait never mind
he's got one of those little cards carry
on friends Romeo and Juliet huh now
those two ended up no dad no wonder this
girl can't get a damn scholarship all
you had to do was report it and now
Lucas is dead right totally dad's fault
about the evil government transformer
assassin but she blames him for a mom
dying too even though we all know who is
to blame they're also how long does it
take for Optimus Prime to figure out if
they were followed buddy someone gave
that order I find something a present
you're fucking going to do what
thankfully the place Optimus told the
inventor to hide and wait is basically a
backup inventors workshop this guy
doesn't immediately swat the hell out of
this drone after he sees it oh look the
food vendor can now control the chaos I
drone with an Atari controller
good for him stupid cops they're not at
the ATM they're at the second most
obvious place that Ridge up there that
you're not looking at movie filetes
itself Oh find you Vina combis oh good
more racial stereotypes these are aliens
from a different world right they're
picking us off one by one how I mean if
they're able to do that then how the
fuck does this scene even happening all
five of you out in the open with a
fuckin campfire
I don't think the kill squads are
actually very good at finding you well
for the record
superdad I'm not hiding with you online
now with that big guy
it's either assume that this actor is
terrible and inconsistent with an Irish
accent or it's a sin that this Irish
actor doesn't sound Irish 50% of the
time
regardless it's annoying it's Joel I
still recorded footage of an Autobot
raid in pieces watch what happens here
the footage changes like an old VHS tape
and then designed this drone which they
can't control or find Chicago did not
get built back in five years that would
have been nearly a generational thing
with that much damage
Chicago ksi headquarters is like a
fortress I'm gonna find a way into the
top-secret military wing find something
to blackmail his company and the
government movie rips off the screenplay
I wrote when I was 7 movie introduces an
entirely new character nearly an hour
into the movie also I see this movie's
John Turturro or John Malkovich will be
played by Stanley Tucci thanks for the
laughs dude what was that sound I don't
know but I'm sure movies gonna spend a
lot of undo time on it also it's
probably the sound of everyone in the
audience snoring at this point
transformium
that's what we're calling it is this a
dumber name than unobtainium probably
not but still don't you like music I own
I probably say something about this
beats by dre Bulls but I'm honestly more
concerned with how he's controlling the
programmable matter with his mind and a
flick of his hand because that's a more
amazing scientific advancement than even
discovering programmable matter Hey
about a whole bunch of boxes of clothes
just lying around next to a goodwill
nobody was using them he stole mouth
wash I like to be fresh when I'm liking
our your daughter
here's another Michael Bay film
populated with people who do and say
things normal people would never do or
say movie set design 101 don't give two
shits about logic why would the design
team and the production team be in the
same room why is work being done here
requiring some to wear safety suits but
others to just wear street clothes do
you care of course not
you just want a place to show us
Galvatron a model of Galvatron after
Optimus Prime
why does he keep looking like Megatron I
don't know but I bet it means that's
Megatron simple coding I'm not seeing
stanley tucci hasn't occasionally whored
himself out for money in the movies but
even he has to be a little embarrassed
about what's going on right here
YouTube's Kassem G gets a cameo in the
Transformers sequel but ends up right
back on YouTube getting mocked by us
we're still assholes but probably not
for this did that alien robot just make
a Dirty Dancing reference so we can bill
them ourselves
we can build another you just had a
tantrum about how you couldn't build
them better you could even build them
the same which one of these fucking on
the run desperate assholes took the time
to light all the rosary candles
throughout this church answer none of
them Michael Bay lit them because the
shot is always master to logic or common
sense is this line supposed to be ironic
because who says square anymore you talk
to me like that I'm beginning to think
bumble bee doesn't even want to get his
real voice box fixed inspired by bumble
bee but better in every way movie will
now waste time insulting bumble bees so
that he will go unnecessarily ballistic
also who did they make this stinger
commercial for then you gotta calm down
right now I'm perfectly calm the movie
hopes reference to The Big Lebowski
we'll give it some street cred but movie
and franchise has gone on way too long
for that to be a possibility why are
they running a documentary about their
new robot design in the very room where
the robot is being designed to motivate
the scientists you came to me on this
remember you retire from the CIA clunky
exposition is clunky you need to deliver
the scene Caesar Flickerman just asked
Frasier Crane for semen I am officially
giving up my fanfiction career high tech
government facility can't detect when
strange drone activity is happening same
badge code scanned in two separate gates
instead of doing security things about
it we came to find the head of the
entire company to ask what we should do
Kate escapes because this laboratory
makes no fucking sense it's not a
Transformers movie if bumblebee isn't
changing into the most recent stupid
Chevy muscle car design there is a
version of this conversation where you
get to go back to your barn
uh you have no idea what you're involved
with here really my reply to that
comment requires the removal of my
glasses Oreo BOTS also about the overall
bottom line production costs ended up
being like 20 bucks after the car beer
and snack money came rolling in I broke
the code I own your whole genome except
I can't get my Optimus Prime clones to
come out looking like anything except
Megatron clones but you get the gist
we're done a little bit character voice
is my main complaint with this entire
franchise it's never been tested in the
field invention that has never been
tested in the field is going to go out
into the field cliche were they not
literally just in the heart of downtown
Chicago because I've been to Chicago and
you can't drive from the heart of
downtown in any direction and be in
countryside this opened within a few
minutes
ever hear of urban sprawl I feel like
I've seen this enough in the other
Transformers movies that putting it in
this one is excessive pointless more
stupid well this sort of defeats the
purpose of transformers altogether
doesn't it Kate and Shan new to jump out
of Optimus but somehow didn't tell Tessa
the plan also how did Kaede and chain
jump out the same door Tessa was in the
middle so that means Kaede climbed over
his daughter to jump out of Optimus well
that chick is fucking dead Tessa runs
into the field and after a small sample
size of results decides that the road is
still the safest place instead of you
know running into the cornfield across
the street when you don't have a good
reason for a character to constantly be
in peril just make the giant robot fight
follow her everywhere she goes I promise
no one in the audience will notice how
ridiculous it is that's my asset both
Galvatron back dude you ordered the
untested Galvatron to go out there when
you have this awesome terminator about
to use its lockdown like a person who
can't open a pickle jar and someone
loosens it and that's when you can
finally open the pickle jar who sent you
here you think you were born no you were
built and your creators want you back
movie keeps villains true motivations
for hunting prime a surprise for
basically no reason and again makes us
wonder if these robots to procreate or
not no I wonder if we made all the slow
motions in this movie into regular speed
if the formerly three hour runtime
wouldn't come closer to 75 minutes the
deals gone down now picking up the seed
at the Recon point so why is the recon
point to make this deal in downtown
Chicago they could have just sent one of
these helicopters out of the cornfields
and prevent the general panic that the
spaceship caused unfortunate accidental
kidnapping leads to extremely fortunate
and convenient eavesdropping a deal is
done one prime for one seed how did this
deal ever happen did this guy come to
earth hunting prime as his last
collectible Knight and instead of just
finding and taking him make an
unnecessary bargain with a government
entity how did he know who to call on
that anyway and did the humans send out
a space message asking someone to come
and sell them seed these dickheads
managed to not only drive here in record
time and beat Chicago traffic but
managed to get to the exact spot where
the ship landed with no issues come on I
guess we know why now this took place in
downtown Chicago so that our heroes
could get on the ship hey I'm not here
to help you get your daughter
you're here to help me get my girlfriend
this guy has one line and he just
changes the particulars every time he
says it engage da Matta drives
how does lockdown not know he's got a
bunch of intruders on his ship
lockdown ship has booby traps but
apparently nothing to hear loud yelling
or any other kind of security feature
you